PUUSSIA IS FOUON UCHE,S MOVE TXA
OF THE CNTRYR WHAT THE
U.S. AND THEFE
CNN'S SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
RR
OK'S PLAN  G OUT.
TOPRESIDENN VOWING SUCCESS
IN UKRAINE AFTE
NONT
E INVITED CROWYELLED  B THIS CAP
Y USG HIS  TO ARMS
CASESTAKES
N ONS AM REFERENDUM SHOWEDR
MOSCOW'S RULN
EGION WAS NOT >> Translator: TH.
RUSSIA NOT GOING T HISSSIA'SRTF
,  THAT LIES D  C
HE DMID THAT ANY ATTACK E ANNEX
ANOSAL IINE TRIE
DU ALA RUSSIA.IR M
ISHEEFIELD ING ITS WORSTE
RUSSESTSGARY.ILE ATOM T'S B
THERE'S ALSO IS GLOB
NATION IMPOSING FRESH
SANCTIONS AGAINST RUSSIAN  OTHEG
AND IN U, ESZELENSKYY CALLED MO
OF T E FREE TO JOINATO. TransKYH
>> ReporSQE D NTTO SEND PORF AT
ND
E HE
N'S RUSSIA ITAKE THIS PA
>> ALL RIGHT.R THANKS TO MATTHE
THAT RUSSIHTERS HAVE TRIED
TO FORTO BREAK THROUGH
THBLOCKADEBUT THEIATTEMPTS HAVE
ESSFUL.
IT'S GETICATED.H WOULDAINE MORLR
ING IN RETIREDLIEU MAR
AL
EUROPE AND T ARMY.
TEENERAL, E QUESTION IS
ABOUT TOEE A E
NOW, WELL, I CERTAIN, LK A AT'SG
SUSEARA,U JUST
AR THE C LYMAN WIAN FORCES HE SD
CITY. RUIAN TROOPS IN THAT K
IN ONE OO BLOCKS THAD  FALSIFIEM
THE ALOF GOI
NA ODES.UKINFORCES ARE IBOTH LUN
SECURE THEIE
IA IE UTH AN THE CAPALTHOSE O IY
MR. TIAINS
D THET
GENERAL, WE'VE BEEN HEARING OVER
ER AINDED TH IWITH TPAZAONUSSIAO
T IN THE CR WITH
THE LITARILYHE'S
IN
SO, WH THE
BEYOND SANCTIONSE SEEN
WI TAND
TH PREVENT
PH RS ANNETIRAF UKRAINE?RIMEA LD
2014 ITI A ECONOMIAND PLAT HIS
VE MILITAR
AND UKRAINE  IASINGLY BATTEL
BUT THE SANCTIOND EXPORTARE T A
TERNATIONAL ARMS SUPPL AT WERTIT
US HISE,
ADD T UMA, WLOR
OUEQ.9 MEMBERS OF, THUPR ., FACE
MR. PUTIVING HISH.THERE WERE NO.
AOT BITE ESIDENN SIGNING
A VO T AGAIN, COUNN U'RE GOING O
D  RUSSIA'AL
ANINDIA,RE SUSTAINING -- OR
ATA
S IN DIPLOMACY, ECONOMY MILITARE
WORD YOUD R,
HOSCRIBI PUTINLDENEDERATS
PUTIN RIGHT NOW, ESPECIATHOF TH.
ARE.KNOWI'M CHAM. THAERE H
HUBRIS IN THF FAIL
VE P JUST
AN STILLMACHIAVELLIAN APPROACH O
ARD.
ANS NOTHING TO MANEUVE
RIGHT NO'S BEEN ON W
AND HIS ECONOMISYET HE'S STILLD.
OPERATIONS YETUL I OR GI
SO JUST UBLING-DOWN INDICATES M
TIME FOR-END WNSE TO EP THING
>> I THINKHA
HAPPENING T RECENT
TRANCHE OFT ED YTE.D HOPES N NET
BUT BUILDINGON THE BATTLE